Uh, what do you, what are your thoughts on the election so far?
Yeah, look, I think overall it's a good thing.
It's a good night for Democrats. Um, you know,
Joe Biden is going to win the white house and he will have, you know,
expanded the map a little bit with, you know, picking up Arizona and, you know,
Georgia, I'm still seeing some weird stuff out of Georgia.
And I think we still have a shot at Georgia. Um,
but the one thing that drives me nuts is seeing still Democrats
acting like we've lost this election,
even though we're going to take back the white house. And you know,
that if that, if Donald Trump were in the same position that Joe Biden more,
you know, right now, um, you know,
in Wisconsin and Michigan and Pennsylvania, you know,
Arizona, that he would be claiming some massive mandate, right.
And instead Dems are still, you know, wetting the bed and, and,
and pointing fingers.
When I think that we should take some pride in the fact that we won this
election.
I think some of that though is like an emotional mitigation to,
to evade like a 2016 heartbreak and be able to
rejoice, uh, when we actually get a positive result. I'm not sure.
Yeah. Maybe. Um, I also just,
I also think that there was such a misfire in terms of the polling,
um, in terms of Democrats confidence, in terms of like the,
if you watch the cable news coverage, right. If you watched MSNBC, CNN,
you know, you're obviously going to be a little bit let down from,
by these results. But, um, you know, a lot of people got,
got some things very wrong in this race,
and I think that's going to be something that we're going to have to examine
afterwards.
As we're talking about this.
And this just happened with wi Wisconsin and Def officially fell for Joe
Biden. However,
that poll was somewhere between nine points to 17 points for
Joe Biden. Um, and like good quote unquote, good pollsters. Um,
they're obviously not good. They're terrible. And this poll,
this state like Biden clearly won it, but by 21,000 votes,
like that's essential tie. Um,
so what I'm like, my mind's blown. I'm like, Oh, and like, you know,
this from working in communication in general, like being on the campaign where,
how much, I think the media misses things,
or like the people on one side and like the narratives are on this other side.
Um, so like, if you had to guess, like what,
why are the polls so off? Like why is it a narrative so wrong?
Is it because they're bad pollsters, maybe that's it. Or is this like,
is there's this media buyer that's fueling it? Where do you land on that?
It's combination of those two? Um, and look, a win is a win. I,
I don't care. [inaudible] right. Like I, as I,
uh, my view here always was Joe Biden just needs to win by one vote in Michigan,
Pennsylvania, Wisconsin. I don't give a about a ran date. Okay.
I just want to win here. Um, and sorry, sorry.
Sorry for my language. Um,
but I do think that sometimes I think that the political class and the,
the political professional class does sometimes just miss the Mark
on Donald Trump and does not understand his appeal and, um,
always how to, how to reach his supporters.
And I think that that's going to be a story of this campaign too,
is that once again, like in 2016, the pollsters, um,
didn't quite captured, uh, you know, Donald Trump's enduring strength.
And that's one of the things that we've seen down-ballot right,
is a lot of the races, um, that we lost, you know, Senate races,
house races were in tough red districts and that, you know,
Donald Trump performed really, really well. And,
and there's a view that he's like this an barren monster and that no one is
going to support him, just really doesn't comport with the facts.
And I think that we've got to understand that, you know,
he is a Republican and he is like,
I H Republicans are going to back him and that he's not just history's greatest
monster and that people are going to run away from him in droves. So,
so true. Um, Eric, I saw your mouth when you're going to say something, sorry.
No, no. I was just nodding my head along with,
with everything that I was talking about. I do, um,
I do want to talk about one of your superpowers and obviously it's something
that I've been wanting to chat with you a while about. Um, you know, uh,
obviously we both worked for candidates, um, that,
uh, ran in a very crowded primary. Um,
and I'd be lying if I said I didn't, uh, work towards, um,
at least, uh, your earned media capabilities and,
and looking at different and emerging media, uh, like podcasts and other things.
Um, I applied those lessons both to my time for Tim Ryan,
uh, as well as with Andrew gang, um, uh, for two reasons, number one,
uh, it definitely seemed like it was working a number two. Um, just like Pete,
you know, I got to work with two messengers that were comfortable, uh,
being able to, to work in those environments. Uh, now, you know,
obviously the General's difference, um, and, uh,
both candidates have collective name ID going into the general, uh, and perhaps,
you know, obviously being more comfortable in those controlled environments,
but I think back to your New York times, op-ed back in the spring, uh,
in terms of guidance, uh, for the Biden campaign. And do you feel like, um,
you know, uh, embracing more of those strategies would have helped more,
uh, in helping shape, uh, the outcome going into election night?
Um, so I don't know,
I don't know that I've seen enough where I can definitively say that I
do generally think that communicating more and being more transparent and
available is a good thing. Um,
and being out there more is a generally a good thing. And, you know,
I think we can all admit that because of the constraints of the, um,
as a coronavirus of, you know,
running in the middle of a global pandemic that, that did sort of, um,
uh, hold down, you know, Biden's ability to get out there a bit more. Um,
and I think that they effectively use surrogates.
I know Pete did over like 170 interviews on behalf of the Biden
campaign, which is nuts. We just tally that up. Um,
but I always think I, and, and I'm not gonna,
I don't want a Monday morning quarterback.
I don't want to do anything cause everyone's got to run the race,
but my general advice to anyone running for president,
anyone running for any office is to get out there more and to,
to be a little bit more, you know,
to always try to be aggressive and visible with the media and especially with,
um, you know, outside of the political bubble. Right. And that's a good,
that's something that you guys did on the yang campaign. You know,
I know a lot of Democrats were critical that he went on like Joe Rogan,
but give me a break. How are you going to turn down that audience?
It is massive.
And that's part of the reason game of Thrones Sunday night prime time. Right.
Exactly, exactly. And it's like, that's,
I think that was sort of like one of your first big moments, right.
Is when you did that. Um, and I think that, you know,
sometimes Democrats can be a little bit precious about, um, how we communicate,
how much we communicate, um,
when really what we just need to do is just go out there and get our message out
there.
Yeah, no, I agree. And, and piggybacking off of that though, um, you know,
you were just on a bill show,
which has a marginally better reach than yang speaks here, but it's fantastic
marginally. Uh, but, um, you know, uh, bill asked you about on the,
on the, you know, these Trump car caravans, I saw one of the scares. Um,
but, uh, you know,
he mentioned why we didn't see these things on the democratic side,
and you said so eloquently because we're not a call,
which I thought was hysterical. Fantastic. Um,
but like, do you feel like we need to be,
is that something that's missing?
So I've, you know,
this is something I think about from time to time I've thought about, um,
and no, I just don't, I don't think we need to be. Um,
and there are real life consequences to, you know, the behaviors of,
um, you know, the, of the manga people, right. You know, you see that,
that study that showed that, you know,
700 people who had attended Trump rallies, um, you know,
passed away from the COVID from COVID and you know,
that there were thousands and thousands of,
of COVID infections that they could tie,
COVID-19 getting infections that they could tie back to those rallies. Um,
but no, I do think that's passion is a good thing though,
and that is something that we could probably,
that we should always work toward and, and, um, in our politics.
But I don't think that we need to become like a cult.
There's probably some good middle ground. Um,
I also just don't know that this was the election cycle for that sort of
attitude among, you know, among Democrats. Right.
I just think a lot of us ended up coming down to, um, Joe Biden,
being someone that people were comfortable with he's uh, uh,
and someone that they trusted enough to sort of lead us through the fallout of
the Trump presidency. Um,
I don't think that someone like a Bernie Sanders who definitely does have a lot
more of that culture personality, um,
I don't think we would be sitting here talking about a win if he had been the
nominee, even though he inspires a lot stronger feelings.
Yeah. What would you, what would you say? And you have the map obviously,
and how, how seemingly divided things look, what would be,
you know, an early great public facing opportunity, uh,
for the Biden transition to look at,
as they're trying to bridge the divide and bring the country back together after
what will seemingly be,
not a very easy transition to say the least.
I think he's, I think it's an opportunity to go big. Um,
and this is really an opportunity to show,
to be the opposite of Donald Trump to be the opposite sort of,
of the GOP generally. Right. Um,
Donald Trump has been very divisive.
The Republicans in the Senate who are likely gonna just
continue to do what they've been doing for the last question of the years are
going to be very diff divisive and partisan.
And so I think it's incumbent upon Biden to sort of set the stage that, um,
uh, that he's going to try to work in good faith, try to bridge the divide.
And I think he's got to just try to do that sort of know,
palette to have that sort of pallet changer of a moment. Um,
I don't think it makes sense to come out guns, a blazing being super partisan.
Like we're gonna, you know, Ram all this stuff down your throat.
I think he's got to try to strike, um, uh, a more, you know,
a more positive unifying message at the beginning and find him
an, uh, powerful, symbolic way to do that.
What do you guys think?
Yeah, Andrew said something really interesting a while back. Um,
and you said Joe Biden becomes a really interesting figure because of the lane
he's in no matter what he says, it becomes a new normal,
or at least normal for the Democrats. And so Biden and we,
Joe Biden came out for cash relief for universal basic income.
If he comes out for a version of Medicare for all,
or at least a better government healthcare option, um,
or anything climate is like climate change plan is pretty aggressive. Um, like,
so like if he does that, that becomes way more normalized, you know,
than if Bernie ever did it or no. Yeah.
And I think he's got.
To go on the account. Like I,
I just think right now is climate change is so important, but he's got a really,
I think this is the time to really push through sort of more of an economic
message. I agree.
I agree way of employing empathy will be, uh,
greeted positively overall. Um,
and I think the things that he was so famous to be remembered for during his
Obama years will have a greater display.
And once he gets to move out of this campaign mode,
and I think that's what people forget,
and I think that's what his bread and butter truly is. So, um,
I think some of his natural capabilities will help play a role in how he helps,
you know, bring the country together in some.
Respects. Yeah, no, I agree with that.